in five four three two one welcome
everybody to another episode of the
genius brain lissa podcast we are with
the og cast today and today's video is
going to be another patreon submitted
help we're not gonna call it a vise
we're just coming to be called helping
talking helping talking time we call it
genius suggestions is what we'll call I
like that
so smack genius suggestion it's not
advice legal [ __ ] I never give out
advice I just tell people what I do yeah
these are just suggestions and a lot of
you guys have great great questions to
ask and looking at the likes and seeing
what people want to hear about the only
way you can ask is on pet 30 on so make
sure you join that mmm-hmm here we go
let's start with this one this person's
name is two qingyang that's that's
sounds like good really dope restaurant
to qingyang huh either you're Korean or
you are Hmong I'm not sure how to deal
with people who you don't get along with
but cannot get away from because they're
part of your family oh so this there's a
lot more here y'all ever know somebody
that you dislike so much that whenever
that person opens their goddamn mouth
you just want to slap the [ __ ] off their
face yo hurt them not kill them you know
punish them Joe Malians die oh you slap
I'm not a living life out of that mother
[ __ ] my heart is 99.99% love but that
point zero one percent all goes to hate
and it's really hard for me to dislike
someone even just a little I'm the kind
of person who usually only has positive
and rarely neutral feelings towards
other people I don't like holding
grudges nor do I hold many but once
someone gets on my bad side oh I will
never forgive them or give them any such
respect anyways let me rant y'all ooh I
like this [ __ ]
thank you I like this I like it when you
guys give us background a little because
it helps us to you know better form our
suggestions I know someone who lives
life easily by that I mean by living off
of people's money oh my god
Wow pays for nothing except internet and
does not want to share the password even
though I literally the one and only
thing they pay for it's just like a
sibling sounds like it
sounds like a loser talk about the
brother-sister watch it's their dad is
it oh my god [ __ ] funny dude
he goes by the name father not only that
but he goes by the name father okay oh
not only that but this person only ever
thinks about his own damn self and does
not give a [ __ ] about other people
treats everyone like [ __ ] but expects
everyone to give them respect and return
it really doesn't like Asian dad I don't
give a [ __ ] what happened them in the
past but you have no excuse for being
this much of a mooching lowlife
bottom-feeder Wow pick a sit pick a pick
a tzimmes a pessimist ask maybe
pessimist pessimistic ass pick asommus
that might be a word i don't ever
[ __ ] know so you might be that much
smarter than me but I'm just gonna say
miss pessimist how can you deal how can
you quote unquote deal with someone who
you know you don't get along with but
will end up seeing them anyways the PS
this person is my uncle and wait wait so
so you you have a feeling there monk
probably monk just from the yang Yang Oh
yang Irving or yang vane here's the
thing man what I've noticed though so
okay there's there's multiple ways to
answer this question so this is a really
good [ __ ] question yeah but the first
thing that pops into my mind is just in
certain cultures like having that family
around all the [ __ ] time yes so it's
a part of it right so like I know like
hispanic/latino a lot of Asian cultures
like it you just can't run from it but I
also think that's what keeps the culture
down mmm cuz you can't abandon your
family cuz I'm gonna say some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] but I believe in abandoning your
family well I do too yeah and and some
people are like nah man blood is thicker
than water you can't do that through
your family and I'm like nope [ __ ]
are [ __ ] and good people are good
people and regardless if they have my
blood or my last name I have know if
people give up on me and I
keep working on them and they just
cannot change distance makes the heart
grow fonder you know I'll give a great
example of that what what do people
think about deadbeat parents right run
from them right [ __ ] them
so does does you know a lot of people
might disagree with this but because I
came from your ballsack does that mean
that you are my parent or is that just
me my genetically you're just my dad
yeah those are two different things for
me right from being a parent to an
actual father or or a mother two
completely different things I am by
blood related to you but you depending
on who raised me who put time into me
who loved and cared for me is there they
are my parents yeah so it goes the same
thing with family and the hard part is I
think especially because you're Asian
it's hard to run away from family
because I think the positive and also
sometimes it can be negative part of
Asian culture is that family sometimes
is everything it is it's like how you
conduct yourself how you in the outside
world directly affects your family
because they're afraid of shame and what
you bring to the family yeah but they're
too controlling that you have to try to
control your career your love life
everything it's a part of the culture
but I don't think it's beneficial yeah
like I don't see the positive in that
ever yeah well I don't know I'm gonna
take that back but I think like here's
the thing man you got a sometimes this
is a very precious point in people's
lives in the 20s in their inner in her
late teens or whatever that you need to
figure out who you are as a human being
and you can't do that when you're
spending a lot of time pissed at people
like how many hours are you [ __ ]
pissed at uncle vang you know like you
you walk into the living room and you
see the stinky depress loser of a human
being [ __ ] blowing his money on beer
and he's sitting there to your Dee's
drinking and you're stewing because
you're just watching him for three hours
or you're maybe you're even arguing with
Uncle van for three hours you robbed
yourself three hours that you could have
been developing yourself you could have
been working now you could have been
[ __ ] thinking about your next goals
some
but you decided to waste it on uncle
Wang also - maybe a good point because I
I understand the frustration I trust me
I'm right there with you if I had a look
at a piece of [ __ ] every [ __ ] day I
probably lose my [ __ ] mind
right but however there the I guess if
we are trying to give you something
positive or something good to take away
from this you also have to understand
what's within your control from what I'm
gathering to at this point it's that you
probably live in a household that is
your parents and uncle uncle ding dong
comes over or he might live there he
might live there and it's your parents
choice to have him around yeah family is
family and they love him because he's
family even though he's a [ __ ]
you're not gonna change your parents
perception of their family member no
matter what I hope I can say that he
molested a dog and get him kicked out I
would [ __ ] sabotage the relationship
I saw him [ __ ] our Chihuahua yeah and he
would not let go he kept by saying yo
get a taco but Hulk's my my my one of my
family members this little sweet sweetie
pie she recorded a conversation and
caught someone and brought it out as
evidence during a fight and I was like
you sneaky little devil and I'm like I
am proud of you that's so [ __ ] funny
you are a [ __ ] but you know what
you're [ __ ] smart and a lot of these
kids and my family they're [ __ ] smart
dude they'll catch you they'll be like
that was an inconsistent thing and I
love that because in my generation with
our older generation we weren't able to
do that [ __ ] we would catch our parents
lie we would catch their stupidity their
hypocrisy we couldn't challenge them or
else we get [ __ ] up right so when I
see these kids do that I'm like good you
[ __ ] do that you catch these [ __ ]
idiots for what they did or you give
them a challenge and um you know yeah
that's what you you want to you want to
help them grow and become smarter right
so in this boy situation I would say for
me personally I wished that I moved out
faster and I was alone faster mmm
because
you can't waste your time in your life
worried about other people and how much
they annoy you yeah you need to [ __ ]
worry about what you're gonna be doing
in life how much money you're gonna be
making who you're gonna be [ __ ] like
all these things that are way more
important than some [ __ ] up family
member and you need to run away from
your parents if they're trying to
control you all day and tell you what
you should be when you grow up when you
should like all those things you need to
get the [ __ ] away from you need to
develop yourself as a human being you
need because they're not respecting you
and I would ask to is in terms of the
source of your anger I understand that
it's hard to look at somebody who's like
that but a good thing that I've learned
to do is if somebody is a [ __ ] up and
they are incapable of change yeah why
waste your time holding your breath
waiting for that person to do better
yeah what's the [ __ ] point yeah you
cannot you cannot
I know people who will not change and I
became better and I became more at peace
because I understood that that person is
a [ __ ] and I go you're a [ __ ]
dumbass and I accept you for that and so
when you walk around and you uh you you
run into a brick wall teeth first I go I
expect that in a little Peter yeah and
it's only making you crazy to expect a
different outcome because it's that's
the definition of insanity is doing the
same [ __ ] over and over again expecting
the same outcome I mean a different
outcome so like if you cannot absolutely
move out and be independent arm and you
have to stay with [ __ ] uncle dumbass
yeah and he's mooching off your parents
or mooching off of everybody else a
great exercise for you to learn how to
deal with someone who annoys you and
change your perspective about them and
this is this is some next-level [ __ ] and
a lot of people don't get to this mental
exercise until later on in life but this
is a good opportunity for you to try
this out so every time you hate somebody
or every time you're annoyed of someone
it's the story you're telling yourself
about him yeah right so in this guy's
story uncle dingdong is a moocher he's a
lowlife he doesn't
so all this [ __ ] is shit-talking now
this might be true but if you tell
yourself a different story about uncle
[ __ ] face you could be like well uncle
[ __ ] face fought in the [ __ ] Vietnam
War and maybe he's just a little bit
PTSD so and he doesn't know any better
because he's only got a third grade
education and uncle ding-dong you know
just went through a divorce so he's a
sad piece of [ __ ] yeah
maybe uncle ding dog the reason why your
parents are keeping him around is
because maybe one day back in a day he
rescued them out of something and they
felt like Uncle Dean dong should be you
know like saved and so there's so many
stories you just don't know but if you
have a positive story that you could
tell yourself your perspective of Uncle
[ __ ] will change I think the hard
part for people in those situations it's
like am I make just making excuses for
somebody that doesn't deserve this type
of empathy and respect true but there's
the other side where it's just you're
not really creating a story to cover up
for them no you're really just doing
something for your sanity yes it's for
you yeah only for you because and trust
me I get it like I gotta keep saying I
get it too because there are some people
who I've had a conversation where you
know every time they [ __ ] up it was
like hey let me tell you why this
happened when I was a child
somebody licked my butthole and you know
after a while like I can shut up but
sometimes we don't give a [ __ ] yeah
you're right much once we get burned so
many times yeah I I'm sorry that you
went through that but I don't have to
stick around and get [ __ ] over because
you because of something to happen in
your personal life yeah right cuz I also
have a choice to leave and get out so in
this situation because it doesn't seem
like you really do have an exit because
this person is within your family you
also have to understand that the control
it's not on your part that's also the
family members who choose to keep them
around yeah so if you if you do what Joe
says and you kind of create this reason
for why this person is the dumbass it
really helps you deal with your personal
emotions because what you'll find out
and why this is such a great exercise
you will deal with this at your job yep
your workplace
everywhere your relationships with the
person
you're gonna spend the rest of your life
with this is such a good exercise yeah
it's a good skill to develop but like I
said it
most people don't develop it until later
on in their life but that's what makes
you a stronger person is when you can
control someone annoying you so like for
example like Rob's I mean this is some
next-level [ __ ] but when someone does
annoying you too it's because they're
actually bringing out an insecurity in
you and this this whole thing is really
about you it's not about this [ __ ]
like there's things that unless he's
like literally yelling in your face and
he's [ __ ] abusive and he's [ __ ] up
to you you need to get the [ __ ] out of
there if he's just his existence and the
way he's like communicating is annoying
that's all on you buddy hmm because when
you do have forgiveness and when you do
approach things like with love I know it
sounds pretty stupid but when you do
have that like David says you just
accept the [ __ ] for what he is it's
almost like a dumb dog like you love the
dumb dog because you know that dog just
can't do smarter [ __ ] you know there are
people that I have worked with that I
because and I set myself up for failure
because I had too much open people
that's it that's my man
I expect everyone to be stupid yeah and
you get so mad cuz you expect them to do
better exactly I I always expect these
people to do better because I have a lot
of Hope in them and I see this talent I
see this [ __ ] potential but that's my
fault
right because who's to say that they had
that besides the the narrative that I
created in my head right and then when
they when they kind of disappoint me in
that sense I walk away I'm stomping
around angry and Joe is actually the one
who was like yo what why don't you why
do you keep investing your emotions of
the people that you know are [ __ ]
fuck-ups but oh that [ __ ] that is right
because it's almost like I'm mad at the
dog for being a dog Yeah right
I met a dog for coming in the house
holding his pee and then pissing all
over the floor well you know the dog is
just gonna be a dog I'm mad for the dog
licking my face I don't like it but
that's a dog being a dog right so now I
have approached these situations where
I'm dealing I'm dealing with these
situations a lot better because I'm
telling my
I expect this out of this person in fact
that I expected more out of them is
actually my personal responsibility that
I'm not taking on yeah I mean I I mean
it comes from a good place though
because you care about him so much and
you're just sitting there watching this
guy [ __ ] dig his own grave jump
inside and he's like trying to bury
himself and you're like what are you
doing you [ __ ] idiot and I I mean and
in it I've seen that multiple times
happen in your life with your friends
and then I'm just like cuz you know I
think the only reason why I can see that
is cuz I did that too
yeah and and just just by sheer building
a team and things like that you know you
you you want the best in people but
everyone has their own pace their own
limitations exactly their own and people
will surprise you man like there'll be
people that you think are complete
losers and one day something happens
they make the connections and they
become a star player yeah and there'll
be people who are star players and
something happens and they just go the
complete direct like they self-sabotage
and then they they they hide in a cave
this podcast is brought to you by public
Rec now think about your favorite pair
of raggedy old sweats you love how
comfortable they are to loungin but how
often can you wear them out of the house
without people googling and Goggin at
you like hey who's this trash bag just
wearing sweats well guess what that's
because you don't own the all day
everyday pen from public rec your new
go-to style for comfort and versatility
I'm all about comfort and being stylish
at the same time I've worn these pants
before and people didn't know they were
sweatpants and I like that I like being
stylish enough where people like a those
are dope but people don't know that I
had the flexibility of a gymnast at my
whim in these sweatpants if I wanted to
roundhouse kick somebody in the face
they would be surprised that I didn't
tear these beautiful pants because they
don't know they're sweat pants baby but
they look like making the pants that's
the magic of public wreck that's the
magic of me wearing these out I'm an
ambassador son when I walk around these
pans people are like ooh what's what's
what's going on
what's with the flexibility what's what
- this guy just looking like he's just
in sweatpants and comfortable all the
time it's because of the all day every
day's pants you guys just you just
wouldn't know and I'd like the fact that
people don't know but I also want to
share this with everybody so check it
out
right now you can get an exclusive offer
just for my listeners go to public
recommend today and get 10% off your
first pair of the all-day everyda pants
automatically applied at checkout and
always with free us shipping and free
returns don't sleep on this rare
opportunity to get a discount that's
public Breck that's our EC spelled once
again our EC comm slash brain for 10%
off now because it's like have you ever
had tried to have an intellectual debate
on Twitter with somebody who thinks that
they're smart yeah it is the most
frustrating it's the most frustrating
thing that I that I've used to step into
all the time right yeah it's like you
are actually dumb and they think you're
dumb exactly how do you convince a dumb
person that they're done when they
believe that that the smartest person on
earth and no I don't do that yeah then
they're probably talking to their
dumbass friends saying the same gas the
[ __ ] up that's what Twitter is Twitter
is is a is a place in a platform for not
everybody's dumb I think I like Twitter
a lot just because I makes me laugh line
of Twitter's one of my favorite
platforms ever because there's like
hella hilarious jokes and and there's
like a [ __ ] girl spreading her legs
with [ __ ] fingering her [ __ ] and
then all of a sudden it's the most
random it's like this place crazy
twitter twitter man like you could you
could laugh there you can cry there you
could look for wisdom and you could jack
off all in the same place in a matter of
five minutes I kind of liked it more
than Instagram oh for sure Twitter's my
social media outlet a thousand percent I
think I post more on Instagram but
Twitter is like my guilty pleasure I'm
scrolling a lot through it yeah just
don't interact as much it's it's it's a
fun [ __ ] place to be man like yeah I
definitely enjoyed or a lot just because
I think people have to get really witty
with their words and it requires more
than just putting up an ass photo right
yeah well who have Twitter Fame some of
them are just [ __ ] witty and smart
that's really just crack jokes
24 [ __ ] seven like their meme
accounts is actually clever
thoughts versus like clever pictures
yeah yeah I used to just could wrap it
back around people like I dunno certain
people that I have to be around
sometimes that I can't stand but I I
have to do it yeah off for example when
I go back to Sacramento and I kick it
with a bunch of my friends there's just
one or two people who I could give a
[ __ ] less do they wrote do they still
annoy you and [ __ ] all the [ __ ] time
uh they just say the dumbest [ __ ]
things and I have to sit there and just
be like whatever it's not worth it for
me to cause a scene and you know just
make fun of this person to trash them
and a holiday that's the hardest part is
like when you can't roast them yeah
because I think that's always been my
thing like if someone annoys me I can
just like shut them down
yeah but then then I'm like ah well that
kind of makes me feel weird because then
when you get that they can't control
that yeah and then you know also too
it's just you know at a certain point
when do I start becoming an [ __ ]
because I have a problem with like
disliking somebody and like and I I just
can't hide it very well you know but
everybody else is very good at disliking
somebody and hiding it and yeah and my
thing was this is how I feel it is you
know we're adults now we're not in high
school if you don't like this person you
don't have to invite them over to the
stuff and you know their response is
like well we don't want that feeling
support you don't like them why do you
care I guess not everybody she's built
like that they just like to keep very
thing everything copacetic I think
that's why people aren't they stay
unsuccessful hmm I mean like a lot of
people they care see here's the thing
man validation from others is a huge
thing that humans need yeah I want yeah
and I think that's the number one reason
or not the only reason but that's a big
reason why a lot of people just cannot
be successful yeah like you hear all
these [ __ ] Asian kids talking about
how all my parents don't like they don't
accept my passion so they don't even try
to do what they want to do yeah it's
like because they need the validation
first from their parents to pursue
whatever it's like it's your career you
you shouldn't have to answer to nobody
you just [ __ ] do it
a man my mom said it the best to me she
goes at the end of the day your choices
are your choices yeah what I die you're
left with your choices that's it that's
very smart woman yeah I mean like even
think about like like like females right
like within their group it's so
important for that group to accept the
boyfriend mmm cuz I don't know any
relationships that last where the girl
group does not accept the boyfriend yeah
that that validation is so important you
know like all this stuff is all this
stuff is so important like if you don't
if you don't if you don't like what do
you call it if you're not capable of
just being okay with your own thoughts
and not being swayed by the opinions of
others like people won't get very far
yeah they'll just stay in their own
group of friends they're gonna stay
because then you'll be too scared to do
something different and be rejected by
your friends be rejected by your family
and you'll just be stuck and people say
like you know poor people they're gonna
pop out poor people middle class people
are gonna pop out middle class people
cuz it's the it's the sphere of
influence right yeah the people that
you're around and it sucks because going
back to this guy situation like a lot of
people are dealing with so much stupid
pointless [ __ ] that's filling up their
mind that they're not really killing it
in life cuz let's say like 80% of their
thoughts are on stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] like
this yeah and then the other twenties
probably on their dreams or something
yeah yeah it's it's it's really like
where you want to spend your energy man
like I'm starting to understand that
more today huh [ __ ] funny that we're
talking about this because ma you know
Abe yeah your managers yeah so I you
know his girlfriend to was talking about
a story just like how like in the past
she had a deal with the few people and
she gets like so revved up when she
talks about she's reliving it yeah oh
[ __ ] like I told I was like [ __ ] you
got [ __ ] hate in your heart dude yeah
you get hyped up and revved up about
just kind of ridiculous [ __ ] that
shouldn't affect you so she's not
letting go [ __ ] yeah and also too it's
like
within a conversation - like sometimes
when you have a disagreement with things
you have to really think about why is it
really bothering you why what for what
reason and also the concept of picking
and choosing your battles really comes
into play when you become an adult right
yeah so for example she was talking
about how Mac I forgot who who this
person was but where she was talking
about semantics right where there was an
argument about a definition of a word
and that was causing a spark to fight
about it's like does it really [ __ ]
matter about she was trying to look for
validation yeah it's like it's another
thing of humans needing validation yeah
so she probably wanted you to [ __ ]
agree
so she's I knew us right I knew it yeah
that [ __ ] but that's not how you say
[ __ ] tomahto
yeah it's tomato [ __ ] yeah you
know it's like the I'm right you're
wrong type of stuff and how many hours
did she spend thinking about that [ __ ]
it's a waste a lot of people do this
exactly I am guilty of it for most of my
life yeah and a lot of funny [ __ ] came
out of it but also a lot of [ __ ] time
was wasted yeah man and I wish I caught
on this [ __ ] sooner because I'm a
[ __ ] kill it cuz I'm like I don't
have no [ __ ] like I can catch this
[ __ ] and I thought like people think
we're killing it now man just [ __ ]
wait till we [ __ ] learn how to
control this [ __ ] yeah I think I think a
lot of people who are very successful
also know how to control their emotions
because they understand how to control
their situation very well yeah when I
get upset and I get angry I can't work
and me neither devastates me oh no it
devastates me and it hinders me from
progress which I hate yeah whenever
Marilyn I get into fights she got that
right now whatever and I get into a
fight I'm [ __ ] for the whole day all
right look for three days I get too
angry man I get I get caught up in my
feelings man and I'm just sitting there
just thinking like I can't go to I can't
go to sleep I can eat for sure
I can't go to don't worry that don't
affect my appetite I can't sleep I can't
focus I can't I can't function and
that's why that's why I like controlling
these like factors that you know that
our within your control is the best your
uncle is a [ __ ]
you cannot force him to help pay the
internet bill you can't force him to
stop being an ass
yourself exactly [ __ ] it don't even put
your energy and trying to fix somebody
who doesn't have a will to change that
you got you should all read everybody
should know this change only happens
when somebody recognizes a fault and
they want to change that same thing when
it comes to addictions people people who
don't know that they have an addiction
can fix t an addiction can fix the
addiction if your uncle doesn't know
that he's an [ __ ] and he's a [ __ ]
mooch and he thinks that he's perfect
how are you gonna change somebody who's
perfect how ya and whenever people focus
on others so much I always ask them what
are you running from
hmm you know what are you what like
whenever I put my energy in trying to
change someone else trying to you're so
annoying you're so irritating this guy's
a [ __ ] loser all this stuff right I'm
probably getting a point in my life
where I don't feel like I have much
control over my situation or I'm running
from something yeah that's why I'm
putting my energy into controlling
someone else mm-hmm when you take a
break from that and you go oh [ __ ] you
know what maybe I don't feel that
confident about my studies and I'm not
killing it with my grades or maybe I'm
at work and people are passing me up and
getting promotions and I'm not getting
[ __ ] maybe you know it's it always it
always comes back down to you what are
you running from and it's getting a
little deeper but I think like that is
the most easiest thing that everyone can
just always remember to do is like don't
worry about other people focus on what
you got to do yeah you got to be healthy
right now you got it like and there's
always something to do mm-hmm nobody's
[ __ ] money's right
nobody's health is right yeah nobody's
love is right nobody's friendships are
right there's always something that you
need to be handling and I think if you
could just like boil it down to like
okay I got if I can get better I got to
get more money I got to get a promotion
I got a I got to work out you know deal
with that [ __ ] first [ __ ] [ __ ] uncle
stupid [ __ ] that guy this is the
point yeah well I hope that helped you
out we're gonna go on to the the to the
next genius suggestion we got another
one yep let's do it
we got time for another one so let's do
it uh this is actually a really good one
I like the
Erwin A to B Lara there you guys got
some dope-ass [ __ ] names alright yeah
I got that regular as Christian as names
like David Peters Paul's Mary's you got
that Irwin to be a lotta fool let's look
at your pictures let's see if you're
Hispanic don't be loud to be loud and
look of the dark-skinned nature so I'm
going to add a little accent to it to be
la reforma to be Yara because double
elsewise what are things you do to
success of the league okay first of all
what were these beliefs so 1648 to speak
English what are the things you do to
successfully time manage I know that you
knew Muay Thai genius brain scent foods
manager businesses maintain your
relationship with Mary all do comedy do
you know everything about me huh along
with the plethora of other things but
how do you make time for all this I am
personally a college student doing clubs
maintaining grades trying to get into
Investment Banking and trying to
maintain a social life but I find myself
getting three to four hours of sleep at
night what can I do to regain control
over my life schedule while still making
time for the things I want to do young
padawan you know number one your
situation is different from mine because
you're a student that is a structure
that is very hard to get out of the
things that I am busy with right now I
can choose to structure it however the
[ __ ] I want if and um so your situation
is a little bit different because it's
it's rigid right so school has certain
set hours for the classes that you have
to take yeah and then on top of that you
have to a lot a certain amount of hours
to study which I understand that brain
energy is something that takes up a lot
more than just that two hours that you
were studying it physically takes away
from oh yeah mentally its tolling it you
need time to reset honestly the three to
four hours a night and something I
relate to you because that's about on
average how much I sleep I used to do
that but I don't do that anymore
yeah it's terrible for your mind you
shouldn't do it I think so I wish
someone told me sooner to just focus on
sleep first this podcast is brought to
you by audible my friends audible has
the world's largest selection of audio
books and audio entertainment including
audible originals audible originals are
stories created exclusively for
audio including documentaries exclusive
audiobooks and scripted shows that you
can't hear anywhere else
audible keeps you informed inspired and
entertained you'll finish more stories
when you listen with audible and always
and be a part of the conversation you
know I have not been listening to a lot
of music nowadays especially when it
comes to long rides I listen to
audiobooks on audible and I got to tell
you the best entertainment I've ever had
there are a lot of books that I want to
read but I am always on the go and I'm
telling you I'm in my car a lot so I
definitely refer to audible my friend
specifically I've been listening to a
buddy of mine she actually have has one
of her books the game of desire on there
by Shannon Bertram and I've been
listening to that fan ha stick so start
listening with a thirty-day audible
trial choose one audiobook and two
audible originals absolutely free visit
audible.com slash GB or txt GB - 500 -
500 start listening with a 30 day
audible trial choose one audiobook and
two audible originals absolutely free
visit audible.com slash GB or Tex GP -
500 - 500 today you also have to find
out what you're personally capable of
just because you see you here
you know podcasts of not somebody like
me but somebody like Gary Vee or you
know somebody else and you go well this
is what they did I should be able to do
that - some people are just exceptional
at what they do a lot of the times the
something that I used to fall into that
I [ __ ] up on the most was I used to
spread myself too thin the reason why
I'm not so spread thin right now is
because I have I decided to a lot the
help of people who are better than me at
certain things and we decide to do
things as a group versus doing something
individually for example genius praying
I do it with Joe I could have done it
myself a hundred percent but he'd be a
lot more difficult to sit here and talk
to myself you know also to find like a
returning guest that could speak well
like Joe and I have great rapport and I
decided to do Jesus brain with him
because number one it's fun for me so it
doesn't seem like work number two is the
way for me to hang out with him anymore
at number three it's it's somebody who I
can trust
these are there's ways to time manage by
not spreading yourself too thin if you
want to do multiple projects I don't
know what it is in your case
specifically because you are doing stuff
that requires only you to do it yeah
right well I mean the easiest way I can
see is the set schedules like the
college stuff make that a priority and
then like the studying that that
supports the college stuff and then you
you you schedule around it you create
you got to kind of wipe out all the
other [ __ ] that's going on like
Investment Banking and all that like
that's a career mad yeah right now
you're supposed to be training and
studying like well if you're if you're
[ __ ] Mark Zuckerberg or [ __ ] Bill
Gates you could be like simultaneously
doing it and then you find out at one
point well this is doing much better but
if you're not if in and if this is just
taking time away from you I figure out
something to cut and rework yes I would
figure out how to refocus it's not gonna
kill you you don't you know but if
you're really on the verge of something
with investment bacon or whatever then
jump on that and cut everything else out
so something's got to get cut you can't
do it all and I don't like doing it all
it's just this is my personality I wish
I could be someone that's got one thing
going on yeah
but my mind is constantly going right
and so I figured out to do this
basically thing it's it's a it's a
marcus aurelius from it's like a stoah
stoah stoah k-- or stoicism yeah I think
he's the founder of that but he he
figured out how to be productive and
actually kill it in a just a handful of
things cuz his I think he was doing [ __ ]
all over the place in ancient Rome but
you write down 25 things that you want
to accomplish right and then all those
things you know like let's say you want
to learn karate or you want to [ __ ]
be really good at basketball and then
you want to do Investment Banking and
then you want to graduate college or
whatever right you write all those
things down and then you circle the top
five things so you have your investment
banking you have your college and all
that you have to look at it
and look at how much hours it's gonna
take to actually kill it you might have
to replace one because realistically if
you're trying to have a career while
having a full time like you know as a
student because the student is a
full-time [ __ ] job man yeah
something's got to give man you got to
look at it realistically and be like
okay this is why I'm sleeping three
hours somebody that I know that worked
really hard
he doesn't do Investment Banking per se
but John Chiang right yeah
John Chiang is somebody who number one
night I admire a lot specifically in the
sense of how he's built up his own
empire and financially he's really
[ __ ] well but I'm actually good we
should bring him [ __ ] on oh yeah
that'd be great to hear his story it was
yeah he paid for his own college I mean
he's a multi multi-millionaire yeah and
this guy too
he's in he's in commercial real estate
okay that's this and the reason why he's
so successful is because he's also very
singularly focused he only does
commercial real estate only commercial
real estate and even as he was working
himself on you know - his way up he
didn't have a social life he actually
cut that equation out right he
understood that there's some certain
part of his life that he has to get rid
of in order for him to be accessible
John is all right well he recently got
married oh he got married recently
John you son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] tell me
that not that I want to be imagine to
what he neither right but I just saw a
faith-based Facebook update and I
couldn't graduated him but um congrats
you [ __ ] lations John yeah well he's
the same age as me oh yeah but by the
time he was like in his 20s he's already
a millionaire oh yeah yeah I think he
had about ten million by the time he was
mid 20s or something you know I remember
talking to him and he told me his
portfolio size and everything and how
much I think he was like every month he
was getting like $30,000 or some [ __ ]
like that's [ __ ] crazy man and he
always talks about this openly because
it's I mean in in investments and I mean
people openly talk about how much they
make right but um so basically the real
in summary what he did was he started
trading currency in Hong Kong as an
internship and when
you've studying abroad or whatever right
and then so he learned about investments
and then he worked really hard on that
came back to the states graduated and
then on the day that he graduated he
went into the office and he paid off his
whole entire schooling as president yeah
and then he got interned or he started
at another firm doing commercial real
estate and he just worked his way up and
then he became I guess one of the
partners of the whole whole thing so
that's in summary like he just really
found he had one track and yeah with it
and he went all the way through yeah and
the reason why I bring him up is because
I know that he cut out his social life
because we had a conversation we were
drinking a little bit and then John was
like you know I know people look at me
and they go oh you know he probably came
from a wealthy family and he got you
know spoon fed a lot a lot of this stuff
but his story is not like that at all
though cuz I think his parents are
well-off Dana spoon feed him [ __ ] he had
to make his own success with his own
effort and his own money yeah and he
retired his parents to anyone exactly so
like for him he and you know he goes and
I think what he said to me that was very
[ __ ] profound he goes a lot of people
say that things were given to me but
everybody who says that things were
given to me are also the people who
haven't put in the work like I did and
he put in the work
oh he did yeah for sure he put in the
[ __ ] work and that's something really
to be admired about yeah like I don't
know if he really knows it but I [ __ ]
look up that guy a lot me too man I
always told him like I've had
opportunity in the past like him to
stick with stuff and to be around a good
mentor or whatever but I did it cuz I
wanted to be with my friends and I
wanted to do other things and you know
it took me some time and I mean I feel
pretty fulfilled with where I got to be
yeah
but I also admire people that are
willing to sacrifice and just work at it
until they get somewhere yeah for you to
what's important for you he's trying to
do everything yeah like what cool what
really brings you wealth really think
about that for a second what brings you
wealth isn't a lot of money or is it
relationships that you want to build
yeah because for me I like money because
I understand
that financial freedom helps a lot yeah
but I'm not willing to risk financial
freedom for personal relationships
exactly cuz I could probably make like
10 million right now if I wanted to if
we if I gave up everything if I gave up
Muriel which to me is me saying I'd give
up my happiness yeah I gave up my
parents talking to them personal
relationships unless they just be in
jail we're like hey let's figure out how
to do this I I could do I know exactly
what to do I basically cut out JK and
then move on and then try your own thing
yeah I mean like I already have all the
access to people yeah I would assemble
like a team just of the top
[ __ ] of lawyers of accountants
and I would just start buying and
selling businesses yeah and that is way
bigger money wait like I know bankers I
know like a [ __ ] ton of people that's
just like that's but it's boring it's
like it's fun but it's boring and it's
it's cutthroat yes so like if I if I
wanted to be a certain way a lot of the
people that I have in my company
wouldn't be in my company yeah but it's
cuz I love them and I want them around
and I care about them it's your
perception of wealth like yeah to me I
will deal with certain issues because I
consider them family it's a family
business right versus if I look at it as
a company I'm like uh you [ __ ] up
you're too slow
get the [ __ ] out I need someone faster I
need this I need that like I would
approach it completely differently yeah
yeah yeah and that would that would make
me way more money you know I had a
conversation with Muriel too but towards
the end of this year I told her that hey
I'm not gonna be as present as I was
before so meaning that for the past year
when I you know was losing the weight
and I decided to just focus on myself
yeah our relationship flourished a lot
we stopped fighting we we were
communicating better but when I started
working again a lot of this a lot of the
problems that we had before started to
resurface oh because that's that's that
give and take that you have yeah your
patient starts to run thin you're the
quality times that you guys used to
spend together starts to disappear and
it causes a lot of friction
I had to understand it gave her a heads
up like you know when I'm on I'm on like
I'm gonna be working and I'm gonna be
yeah diving into this podcast getting it
done and then do it working on the stuff
you know and I've booked quite a few
things and I've done really well for
myself but on the ladder and you know
she and I used to spend every night we
used to watch something together and was
the left those are gone now because now
I'm over here working on some stuff
everything's a give-and-take yes I don't
know if he mentioned that he has a
girlfriend or whatever yeah I mean I
mention that but he was talking about
how do I he mentioned that I you know
I'm in a relationship with Mary oh yeah
yeah yeah and she's also a woman who
understands what I do to see that's very
important yeah because there's a
give-and-take and I always tell this to
the ladies when when they go oh I want
an ambitious man I'm like do you really
do you really because a loser will have
all the time in the world to be with you
and you can be the number one here's the
thing about ambitious men right women
love that ambition they love that drive
but they don't know what comes with that
an ambitious man a goal is almost there
woman yeah so temporarily when they're
courting you they're excited they're
happy but there's gonna come a time when
you're number two and when like no one
wants to feel number two and we as
entrepreneurs we do a really good job of
making important women feel unimportant
yeah and it's not really about that like
and I think that they've never been with
an ambitious person person before so
they don't get it they don't ever
understand because like any oh I don't
want to say loser but any other guy
that's not got much going on the woman
is his world yeah and and and um you
know they're used to that
yeah if all of your relationships you
get with a guy and he's like you are my
[ __ ] world and I'll do anything I'll
change my job I'll move to you with
wherever you want to go right that's
what normal relationships are kind of
like unless he's a deadbeat and that's a
whole different story
but in most cases you do have the guy
that's like not got much going on or
he's just
kind of average and not that ambitious
yeah and she'll get bored with them
obviously right because she wants a guy
with Drive and then she gets what the
guy would drive but then he doesn't have
time for her yeah she might temporarily
and they'll be exciting and all this
stuff and then it's like this is awesome
and then you'll have to go back to work
yeah in the way that ambitious guys work
is they obsess and that's how they win
there's no other way you cannot
part-time ambition it just doesn't work
that way
hi a thousand thousand million percent
agree with us it's like how do you win
like if me and you are competitors right
mhm and you're [ __ ] sleeping and
you're doing this part-time 30 hours a
week I'm gonna outwork you yeah I'm
gonna do this [ __ ] 80 hours a week and
I'm gonna I'm gonna beat you and that's
and and that's the thing about ambitious
guys or just in general it's not even
about competition it's just you get so
in love and obsessed and passionate
about what you're doing that you totally
forget about the world yeah
and it doesn't mean that your kids
aren't important or your wife is it's
just the way the brain works and you
lose track of time
because you're like in the zone man like
it's almost like you're writing a book
and you have this like almost like the
power of God or some spirit inside of
you riding through your of your fingers
and you're you've been riding for 12
hours straight no water no peeing and
you're just like oh my god
I'm hungry what happened I had a
conversation we just said I just did a
podcast with my buddy Joe really really
famous artist out and no one Joe I think
there's another Joe and he was talking
about how you know with his lady yeah he
goes there's moments where you know
she'll get a little upset I rightfully
so yeah where he goes did you ever just
sit there and you start spacing on what
somebody's talking to you yeah Mike yes
I know exactly what you're talking about
cuz you're thinking about something else
yeah when I die and an idea strikes
you're like you're trying to grab on to
it yeah so you sit there and then you'll
space space off like Merrill has seen me
do that plenty of times where she's
talking to me and and then my mouth is
open and I'm looking somewhere else is
because I'm thinking of something I
thought of a funny scenario for a sketch
or something and I and I'm trying to
develop in my head
and I and I think that's and I that's
just a small sample of somebody who's
ambitious it's like they they're trying
to constantly expand and become better
yeah and then work all the time and then
and you know people want to be so like
you know the woman wants to be on your
mind all the time yeah like how it was
dating yeah they wanna and and there
comes a time when vacation has to be
over and it sucks like at least for me
right like when I'm courting and all
that like and this is the whole thing
about keeping the relationship fun and
all that you have to continuously court
and that's important too but while
you're in college while you're
developing maybe it's not the right time
yeah so how do like we manage all this
while this stuff number one I didn't
that's why I broke up with the wrong
person dude I am number one I find a
group of people that I trust that I can
work with and by the way that's a whole
other podcast in and of itself to how to
find those people yeah very difficult
very hard but when you do hold on to
those [ __ ] for dear life
because is very difficult oh yeah and
working relationships like that like I
didn't realize how difficult it was to
find a working relationship with
somebody like Joe and Bart I didn't
realize that a lot of people don't have
that they look at they look at you know
when we work together we did Jake and
ears they go how does that work I'm like
what do you mean what do you mean it's
hard do your part
like how do you do how'd you guys do go
for about we did our part and we didn't
and also we don't [ __ ] work with
amateurs that's the thing like yeah
people say that is because they can't
get over that hump hmm when you know
everyone experiences this right you get
together with the group try to do a
t-shirt company you have a falling-out
or whatever and then you can never get
[ __ ] going because they treat this [ __ ]
like a [ __ ] college project one guy
bails one guy's got all this motivation
but he doesn't put in any work yeah
these are all [ __ ] amateurs hmm when
you're ready to put in some [ __ ] work
with some serious people that has done
[ __ ] this is what it's supposed to be
like yeah this is and everyone comes to
the table they work on it right and then
we have the radar now like just being
around enough [ __ ] losers and people
that talk big games and they just
consistently [ __ ] up you have the radar
your
to find another guy and you go okay I
know what you're about and I'm not gonna
work with you yeah there are things that
sometimes you feel that especially when
it comes to business partners that if
they're not if they can't do the stuff
that shouldn't have to be said it's
already a bad sign
yeah I think if I could redo some of
these partnerships that I made I would
have done a preliminary partnership yeah
a little longer it's like cool well
let's we'll figure out these logistics
if we could work within these parameters
what said it was say within six seven
months and a year and we could all
fulfill our promises and and I'm okay
with everything that happens then let's
solidify it a little more yeah I'm Way
quicker I'm quicker to act and cut
people out now but I'm very slow to
bring them in yeah so like I don't do
business with people unless I'm like
we're married like we're good like you
know that lure I'm like I'm gonna trust
you for my life yeah and this is a very
slow process but now I think I'm getting
quicker at being able to find cuz
usually if your friend is legit and then
they vouch for this other person that's
that's the thing about golden people
right it's like birds of a feather that
saying is really [ __ ] true right like
we have some business partners that if
they if someone vouchers or he vouches
for so-and-so
it's like cool you're good with me I
don't even need to work try to trust you
yeah and there's other people where it's
like anyone you introduce they're gonna
be fuck-ups because you yourself is a
[ __ ] or you attract fuck-ups you know
and people go well that's [ __ ] up you
shouldn't judge and I'm like oh no you
should judge yeah for your own sake
especially in business you got a judge
you that part is my [ __ ] biggest flaw
you judge too much I like talent over
you know some of the like the glaring
flaws I'm like Tam I'm just like you
know why it's because you treat skill
and talent as good as character yeah or
as good as like
being competent yeah to me not the same
and I get it too because I think me
knowing my dad very talented musician
very well known
very respected but I understood how he
ran [ __ ] around the house his character
I think just that example got me ready
into the world to realize that a
person's skill does not determine their
ability in everything else yeah even if
they have complex a lot and I could
respect their art I know that this trait
is very apparent an artist is like they
can't do business yeah
yeah the most successful artists that I
know are people who actually put I say
70% business 30% art yeah in terms of
making it into money if you if you want
to do art and you don't want to make it
into a business
that's [ __ ] dope too but don't
complain when you can't make money off
of something that you're passionate
about because there's this whole moving
piece and this whole machinery behind
selling art and making it into a living
yo you don't realize is very difficult
and actually requires more business than
the actual town the skill that you have
there's a there's a [ __ ] ton of purists
out there that are just like I should be
rich and famous being being myself and
doing pure art and doing the road work
man it's it's that same thing where
sometimes people see a certain street
artists or some [ __ ] they pop off and
they go why my shits better doesn't
matter he did the marketing part what
were you doing yep it's all a balance is
what it is well that wraps up this
podcast I hope that helped you out just
by kind of relating it back to our lives
and stuff but a bro it seem like you're
doing it right I mean you you're a
motivated human being which by the way
if you're in college or university and
you just started you're probably 18 or
19 years old I wasn't even there I was
too busy trying to [ __ ] the same [ __ ]
over and over again so I wasn't even in
college yet so good for you look at that
dude so you doing better man and learn
to uh the the other my mom my mom homie
control things that are within your
control let go of the other [ __ ]
uncle uncle but [ __ ] his uncle but [ __ ]
let him but [ __ ] away and don't waste
your energy on that [ __ ] yep so uh thank
you guys for listening once again this
is the genius brain podcast if you guys
see us on all these audio platforms you
know spice Spotify a spy fie Spotify
iTunes give us that five star continue
to share because we're trying to be the
best casual podcast out there happy to
tell me see y'all next time bye-bye